ein eurasischer wirtschaftsraum von
lissabon bis wladiwostok in frieden und
guter nachbarschaft von allen
europäischen blütenträume nach 1945 war
dieser der mit abstand größte seit dem
24 februar wissen alle warum dem
bösewicht die stirn bieten und die
länder zu schützen die freiheit und
wohlstand der putin diktatur vorziehen
darum haben sich die staats und
regierungschefs der eu in brüssel
versammelt ein land steht besonders im
fokus
gipfel in brüssel soll die ukraine in
die eu jetzt in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
hier im studio in antalya friedrich ist
bei uns klinische journalistin die hier
in deutschland lebt immer druck elmar
brok ist war mitglied im europäischen
parlament von 980 bis 2019 sie waren
dort vorsitzender des auswärtigen
ausschusses und auch ukraine
beauftragter der europäischen kommission
mit europa viel zu tun hat auch günter
verheugen mit der eu kommission zunächst
als erweiterungskommissar und dann als
industrie als kommissar für industrie
und unternehmenspolitik schließlich
professor stefan kooths vizepräsident
des kieler instituts für weltwirtschaft
diese zuschauerinnen liebe zuschauer
bevor wir hier in die diskussion
eintreten gehen wir an den ort des
geschehens nach brüssel dort wo auf dem
eu-gipfel der europäische rat die staats
und regierungschefs immer noch
zusammensitzen es gibt viel zu
besprechen
auch wenn der
kandidatenstatus für ukraine und moldau
beschlossen worden ist marlon areal ist
da für uns vor ort mal und ging denn die
entscheidung über den kandidatenstatus
für ukraine und moldau die jetzt
getroffen worden jetzt ging die
eigentlich glatt über die bühne
relativ glatt könnte man sagen denn hier
sind die staats und regierungschefs
angereist um vor allen dingen ein
historisches signal zu senden und zwar
der solidarität der ukraine gegenüber
ein deutliches politisches signal folgen
zu lassen und das ist der
beitrittskandidaten status der hier für
die ukraine und für moldawien erteilt
worden ist die länder haben darauf
gewartet und die eu-kommission die hat
hier noch mal deutlich gemacht in ihrer
pressekonferenz dass das ein wichtiges
zeichen der solidarität der
unterstützung der ukraine aber manuell
micron beispielsweise hat auch darauf
hingewiesen dass das noch gar nichts
heißt über die dauer bis dann ein land
wie die ukraine zum beispiel
beitrittskandidat jetzt ist aber daneben
auch vollmitglied wird das kann jahre
dauern auch jahrzehnte das zeigen
beispielsweise die länder des
westbalkans die ja heute hier natürlich
auch zusammen gekommen sind auf dem
gipfel und so gilt neben dem torischen
ergebnis dieser beitrittskandidaten
ukraine und eben moldawien für das
europäische haus unter jedem dach und
das ist vor allen dingen auf den
westbalkan bezogen ja dann könnte man
auch sagen dass einen freud des anderen
leid kommen wir kurz zum westbalkan
da ist ja heute also heißt diese länder
sind ja eigentlich glaubte schon viel
länger an die europäische an die tür der
europäischen union als die ukraine die
ukraine schaltet sich jetzt vor zu
drängen oder wird vorgeschoben vor diese
länder was bedeutet das eigentlich für
das standing der europäischen union auf
dem westbalkan das ist ja auch eine
krisenregionen
absolut und olaf scholz hat das heute
hier noch mal deutlich gemacht dass er
seit die strategische partnerschaft und
vor allen dingen eine vertrauenswürdige
perspektive für diese länder muss ziel
der europäischen union seien aber dieser
weiß balkan gipfel der vorgeschaltet war
zu dem treffen der staats und
regierungschefs hier heute zum regulären
gipfel der hat dann auch den frust bei
den sechs balkanstaaten dann doch sehr
deutlich spüren lassen edi rama der
ministerpräsident von albanien hat
beispielsweise gesagt aufgrund der
blockadehaltung gegenüber der aufnahme
der tatsächlichen gespräche für den
beitrittskandidaten nord mazedonien
bulgarien würde hier zwei nato länder
nämlich sein land und mazedonien
geiselhaft nehmen und das zeigt schon
auch dass da die nerven durchaus blank
liegen und frust da ist da muss die
europäische union tatsächlich nun viele
schritte nach vorne gehen um dann klare
perspektive zu erarbeiten
die länder sind ja ganz
unterschiedlichen ganz unterschiedlichen
standards auch was die annäherung an
geht aber mit dem verweis auf die
ukraine die jetzt beitrittskandidat ist
und wenn man dann auf dem balkan guckt
wo länder teilweise seit 2003 warten auf
einen weiteren start der verhandlung
zeigt sich doch dass neben dem
historischen signal vor allen dingen
hier eine ganze menge arbeit auf vor der
ukraine liegt und das ist auch noch mal
sehr deutlich geworden die ukraine die
müssen jetzt natürlich auch eine ganze
menge hausaufgaben erfüllen es war gibt
es schon in vielen bereichen noch durch
das assoziierungsabkommen annäherung
aber der weg zu einer vollmitgliedschaft
der stand heute nicht auf dem tisch wohl
ist aber das was heute hier beschlossen
worden dass historisch zu nennen der weg
allerdings einer vollmitgliedschaft
dürfte auch für die ukraine ein langer
werden gut soweit mal ein areal aus
bronze sie beobachten dass weiter vor
ort und in phoenix der tag später werden
sie auch noch einmal auftauchen mit dem
neuesten wasserstand so fiebrig wie
wertvoll ist eigentlich die ukraine für
die eu das ist ja ein wort das der
staatspräsident wird umlands gehe in den
mund genommen hat er hat gesagt auch die
europäische union habe gar keine zukunft
ohne die ukraine was ist das ein kalkül
ist das eine rhetorische kunstfigur oder
was erwartet die ukraine jetzt die
heenes vor allem sehr froh über diese
entscheidung dass es für dieses land ein
sehr guter tag jetzt ein guter tag in
den letzten monaten wo man wirklich in
grausamen krieg steht
das ist nicht nur symbolisch ist
natürlich viel pathos bei diesem tag
über solidarität und ja man man wie die
ukraine unterstützen aber es geht nicht
nur darum dass die ukraine sich jetzt
vorprescht und
irgendwie ganz schnell aufgenommen
werden muss für mich ganz wichtig ist
dass es zum glück jetzt diese debatten
aufhören die tour ist zu die tür ist
offen die ukraine gehört zu europa oder
nicht die ukraine gehört eindeutig zur
europäischen familie und das ist auch
für europa wollen man hatte ja den
eindruck in letzter zeit die ukraine
sollte um jeden preis den
kandidatenstatus bekommen aus
nachvollziehbaren gründen
gibt es da keine anderen alternativen
dass sie jetzt kandidatenstatus hat und
irgendwann mal in die europäische union
aufgenommen wird oder aufgenommen werden
will was
was wird jetzt aus diesem weg oder sie
waren erweiterungskommissar was muss auf
was muss ich die ukraine einstellen
schon der kandidatenstatus ist gar
nichts irgendwie rechtlich definiert ist
das ist eine
politische kunst figur
man hätte auch sagen können die ukraine
ist ein potenzieller weiteres kandidat
solche solche solche haben wir solche
haben wir auch ja also ich messe dem
nicht eine so große bedeutung bei wie
ihre kollegin aus der ukraine es ist ein
signal ein starkes signal aber mehr auch
nicht und meine große sorge dabei ist
dass man
sehr kurzfristig hier gedacht hat und
nicht weiß welch ungeheure belastung
dass herr nicht nur für die ukraine
bedeutet das waren dinge um eure
belastung auch für die europäischen
union selber und ich bin nicht davon
überzeugt
dass unsere mitgliedstaaten bereit sind
diese lasten auf sich zu nehmen so dass
meine große sorge ist dass das alles
endet in einer in einer grandiosen
enttäuschung weil hier was versprochen
wird was er was am ende nicht geliefert
werden kann und deshalb meine forderung
daher würde ich mal nicht mit dem
schicksal eines ganzen volkes spiegeln
kann ja
ist es jetzt erforderlich dass die
eu-erweiterung wieder zu einer absoluten
priorität macht wie das 1999 schon
einmal geschehen ist und wie es dann
aber aufgegeben wurde und deshalb darf
sich die erweiterungspolitik nicht nur
auf die ukraine und moldawien beziehen
sondern es muss jetzt so die anderen
bereits erwähnt es muss jetzt die besten
kann einbezogen werde er seine
beitrittsperspektive nicht seit 2003 die
beitrittsperspektive für diese staaten
gibt es seit dem jahre
1999 bin selber bisher war dabei teuer
gewesen sodass wir brauchen jetzt wieder
eine echte eine erweiterung strategie
wir brauchen den politischen willen ja
das was mit diesem signal heute an
gedeutet wurde auch wirklich zu erfüllen
und den möchte ich gerne sehen diesen
willen herr brok ist die europäische
union mit der ukraine ehrlich umgegangen
jetzt bei diesem verfahren ja ich glaube
dass dieser schritt jetzt notwendig war
aufgrund der politischen zusammenhänge
ich glaube es ist notwendig war dass
dieses bekenntnis zu diesem
kandidatenstatus notwendig ist bevor es
zum nullten möglichen verhandlungen
waren waffenstillstand mit russland
kommt dieses darf nicht vorhand stürner
veranstalter verhandlungs bestandteil
sein das muss vorher abgeräumt sein und
deswegen war es wichtig nicht nur den
kandidatenstatus zudem soll er ihn jetzt
zu geben und das war ist deswegen eine
wichtige politische voraussetzungen
das ist die politische dimension in der
frage dass das länger dauert ist auch
klar und dass wir mit dem fahrer
verwaltungsprozesse nicht vorangehen
kann wie man das mit dem westbalkan
gemacht hat man muss zwischen lösung
finden mit den europäischen
wirtschaftsraum oder solche lösung dass
man schritt und tritt den lenden den
bürgern vorteile
vermitteln kann dass es vorangeht in der
ukraine haben werden als sozius und
handelsvertrag dient kann man ausbauen
zu einer solchen europäischen
wirtschaftsunion auf dauer wie man das
mit norwegen gemacht hat und ähnlichem
und dann ist es nicht eine warteposition
40 soll aber im binnenmarkt und
ähnliches
die europäische idee ist ja dass die eu
europa politisch und wirtschaftlich
einen soll soll gemeinsames recht
geschaffen werden soziale ausgleich für
alle man nennt es ja auch ein
friedensprojekt wenn das so ist
es ist verantwortbar dass vor allen
dingen wirtschaftliche kriterien die
voraussetzung für die aufnahme gerade
der ukraine ist ja das denke ich ist ein
wichtiger teil dabei wirtschaftliche
stabilität hat ja sehr viel mit sie auch
soziale stabilität zu tun und das ist
meines erachtens auch das wichtigste was
die
ukraine jetzt in diesem sehr langen
prozess ich stimme vollkommen zu das war
heute ein signal das ist aber jetzt kein
automatismus der ausgelöst würde aber
wichtiges signal und ich denke wir tun
gut daran uns klar zu machen das
wichtigste was die europäische union auf
diesem weg der keine geben kann ist dass
dort die institution besser werden und
zwar die institutionen im sinne von
rechtsstaatlichkeit
zuverlässigkeit auch der regierung abbau
von korruption all das ist wichtig für
das wirtschaftliche wohlergehen aber
gleichermaßen eben auch für die
politische demokratische entwicklung des
landes das geht hand in hand und
wirtschaftliche beziehungen können hier
immer ein wichtiger türöffner sein was
sind die wichtigsten kriterien für eine
solche aufnahme jetzt generell für alle
länder die aufnahme gehen wir reden
jetzt über den speziellen fall nicht was
man der ukraine möglicherweise eine
abkürzung gewährt aus
sicherheitspolitischen gründen was sind
die wichtigsten kriterien in einem ganz
normalen prozess also es gibt ja dann
die berühmten
kriterien gefordert ob in hagen und da
sind eben die politik und
rechtsstaatliche fast ein jahr ist
glaube ich hauptsächlich vier wichtige
bündel an kriterien nennen kann es eben
politische verfasstheit
rechtsstaatlichkeit muss gelten freie
wahlen und dergleichen mehr also das
politische system das wir in der
europäischen union eben auch leben
ökonomisch bedeutet es eben insbesondere
dass man ja das heißt dort man muss
stabil genug sein um dem wettbewerb im
binnenmarkt standzuhalten das ist eine
etwas
schwammige formulierung der natürlich
keinem wettbewerb jeder mithalten wenn
die regeln fair sind das hängt jetzt
nicht vom entwicklungsniveau ab das
heißt also nicht dass die ukraine
unbedingt warten muss bis sie ein
bestimmtes pro kopf einkommen erreicht
hat um dann erst mitspielen zu können
das heißt es nicht die ukraine wäre
vermutlich das mit abstand ärmste
mitgliedsland nach pro kopf
mit gerechnet aber das muss nicht
bedeuten dass sie deshalb wohl nicht
beitreten kann ein hinweis nicht können
wir auch vielleicht später noch mal
diskutieren
es wartet auch arbeit auf die
europäische union also wir sollten
vielleicht nicht so tun dass wir sagen
die europäische union ist einen idealen
zustand und wir wollen den reformbedarf
jetzt sind eigentlich für alle aufnahme
ist es ja da kommen wir auf jeden fall
noch dazu profitlich diese kriterien die
sind ihnen ja auch nicht neu die sind
die beiden ja schon unter normalen
umständen nicht einfach zu erfüllen wie
kann ein land wie die ukraine diese
voraussetzungen erfüllen ein land das
sich gerade in einem mörderischen krieg
gegen einen angreifer befindet ja das
ist eine gute frage
ich muss sagen ich bin eigentlich sehr
glücklich damit wie diese entscheidung
heute von der europäischen union
formuliert wurde und zwar das der
ukraine ein weiteres status bekommt aber
unter voraussetzungen es gibt es
hausaufgaben die zu erfüllen sind die
sind sehr präzise formuliert also manche
sind so wirklich ganz ganz genau das
sind korruptions abbau das sind auch
also ganz genau dinge bevor am ende des
jahres
geschaut wird wie man sie mit voran
kommt und ob man verhandlungen überhaupt
annimmt ansonsten kann das land weiter
also diese diesen status verlieren wenn
ich mich nicht irre korrigieren sie
nicht dass das gabs noch nicht also dass
es überhaupt zum ersten mal mit der
ukraine mit moldau überhaupt dass man so
macht und ich finde das eigentlich sehr
gut weil das hilft vor allem den
europäischen und demokratischen kräften
in die ukraine das hatten wir schon mal
im prozess der visaliberalisierung da
wurde auch das war für die ukraine
unheimlich wichtig das war ein
hauptthema ich war da andauernd
entschlüsseln und die erwartungen waren
riesig und die fragen ukrainische
politiker waren auch riesig und deswegen
jetzt also natürlich kann man im krieg
all diese voraussetzungen jetzt nicht
erfüllen das ist klar man kann auch
diese diese reform wurde die gesetze
nicht bringen also man kann natürlich
sehen sind das parlament arbeitet nicht
irgendwie normal also die medien man
kann nicht wenn man die bevölkerung mit
einer reform nicht einverstanden ist
nicht tot ist lang mal kurz ansetzen
will ja sagen dass arbeitet wird noch
nicht normal gearbeitet da ist der
reformbedarf noch großer bruch der fall
immer zwei begriffe im zusammenhang mit
der ukraine ein was auch hindernisse
sind auf dem weg nach europa korruption
und minderheitenschutz vor allen dingen
gegenüber der russischen minderheit da
hat man der ukraine auch vorgeworfen sie
hätte in dem fall den vertrag von minsk
nicht korrekt eingehalten ist das sind
das zwei themen vor allem das thema der
korruption dass die ukraine schnell in
den griff kriegen kann
dass die korruption ist in diesen
ländern und auch damit in der ukraine
ein ganz großes problem auch die noch
nicht komplett abgeschafft der legalen
wirtschaft im land das ja der rechte mit
gekoppelt ist wir sehen auch dass das
rechtssystem
noch nicht vernünftigen aneinander
greift und es manchmal sich gegenseitig
aushebelt man hat ja eine reihe reform
seit 2014 gemacht aber das bei weitem
nicht ausreichend aber es geht in die
richtige richtung kinder und ich hoffe
dass diese ereignisse jetzt dazu führen
dass manche hemmende wirkung dies
innerhalb druck die gesellschaft gab
dass sie nun endgültig beseitigt sind
denn die jungen menschen im lande die
jene die mai-daten wollten wollen diese
reform der rechtsstaatlichkeit und
demokratie und ich hoffe die werden
dadurch jetzt gestärkt dass man das mit
großem engagement voran treibt als das
bisher der fall gewesen ist das mit dem
minsker regen die mit geregelt haben
beide seiten nicht eingegangen und in
der ukraine ist es nicht so dass man
benachteiligt ist wenn man zu einer
anderen bevölkerungsgruppe wird dass die
nach nach jahrhunderten von
ratifizierung jetzt die ukrainische
sprache in den vordergrund stellen
wollen dagegen ist nichts zu machen aber
dennoch gab es sich fernsehanstalten und
zeitung in russischen nach wie vor in
der ukraine
und deswegen kann man nicht sagen da so
seine russische diskriminierung ist das
ist ein bisschen russische propaganda
dahin geht dass die russen sogar ein
genozid unterworfen sind den oft unruhig
gemeinsam hat das gesagt wenn ihr damit
sie haben das nicht gemeint aber ich bin
oft nur in der ukraine gewesen dass ich
nicht den eindruck hatte im ungarischen
parlament haben auch abgeordnete sprung
von heute vielleicht sollte man da einen
aspekt der noch rauspicken in diesem
ganzen kontext von
rechtsstaatlichkeit der ukraine
es gibt auch gab auch den vorschlag oder
auch kritik am politischen system der
ukraine dass der präsident zu mächtig
sei und das parlament zu schwach als
eine präsidiale verfassung und das
müsste man zugunsten des
einflusses und der macht des parlaments
verschieben ist das eine möglichkeit zu
mehr rechtsstaatlichkeit in der ukraine
zu kommen wir haben in der europäischen
union präsidialsystem in denen die
präsidenten deutlich stärker sind als
der präsident der ukraine also wurde
dringend raten von diesem thema die
finger zu lassen
die kann man sich die kampmann sich da
werden nur verbrennen das ändert aber
nichts daran dass in allen kriterien die
eben genannt worden sind die ukraine
erhebliche schwere schwerwiegende
defizite hat und die muss ich ehrlich
sagen die zwölf länder die während
meiner zeit auf die mitgliedschaft
vorbereitet wurden haben zum zeitpunkt
des beginns der behandlung ein völlig
anderes niveau der vorbereitung gehabt
als die ukraine sie heute habt der
bericht in die kommission vorgelegt hat
das war jetzt freundlicher
ist erkennbar vom politischen willen der
kommissionspräsidentin befruchtet er ist
außerordentlich wohlwollend
ausbauen das wohlwollen und die probleme
dieses landes werden nur in sehr
versteckte form angedeutet das hat aber
keinen zweck die probleme müssen auf den
tisch und dann muss die eu sagen was sie
zu tun gedenkt um der ukraine zu helfen
mit diesen problemen umzugehen wir haben
doch damals auch nicht die polen die
ungeraden die kirchen bieten wir haben
jedoch nicht alleine gelassen mit den
mit den auch mit dem aufgabenheft wir
haben strukturen aufgebaut die ihnen die
ihnen geholfen haben damit umzugehen
wenn man will ja wenn man will kann man
diesen prozess enorm beschleunigen aber
eine kommission muss es wollen und alle
mitgliedstaaten muss das wort müssen es
wollen und ich wollte dringend dazu
raten alle instrumente die zur verfügung
stehenden jetzt gehst auf den tisch zu
legen oder anzuwenden damit nicht das
passiert was wir mit den westbalkan
start mit der türkei erlebt dass ich da
gleich anschließend ist das eine art
feuerwehr maßnahme eben wegen der
bedrohung aus dem osten wird man da
vielleicht dann doch im laufe der zeit
ab und zu mal ein auge zudrücken sagt
damit alle zurückhaltung prognostisch
gesehen mag das vielleicht zu sein dass
man jetzt auch auf der moralischen seite
sich nochmal verpflichtet fühlt hier
eine gewisse unterstützung zu leisten
aber damit würden wir uns ja keinem
keinen gefallen tun weder der ukraine
noch der europäischen union denn das
wertvollste was wir der ukraine anbieten
können ist genau diese unterstützung
beim aufbau stabiler und dann auch
funktionsfähiger institution das ist die
grundlage für wohlstand und auch für
eine stabile politische entwicklung und
auf dieser grundlage können dann die
ukraine selber aufbauen und ich denke
wir sollten da sehr vorsichtig sein
vorschriften zu machen welche form des
politischen systems das land sein soll
das müssen dann die ukraine selber
entscheiden ob sie ein präsidialsystem
wollen oder das parlament stärken wollen
das ist ja das schöne in der
europäischen union dass das hier kein
einheitsmodell ist sondern dass wir hier
in die unterschiedlichen auch tradition
der länder weiterleben lassen können da
muss also nichts vor gestanzt werden
aber es gibt eben für ein land was so
schwache institutionen hat hier eben
eine menge
weiterzugeben das schöne ist das macht
alle miteinander stärker so ein
absolutes positiv so im spiel da muss
niemand etwas abgeben sondern von gut
designten institutionen am alle ein
vorteil so eine art win win situation so
hab ich das verstanden so fiebrig sie
kennen die europäische union zu leben
schon lange hier wenn sie jetzt die
europäischen staaten vergleichen sollten
die bundesrepublik und die ukraine wo
liegen die aus ihrer sicht die größten
defizite in der ukraine was die
rechtsstaatliche
rechtsstaatlichkeit angehört angeht ja
ein ganz ganz wichtiger grund ist für
eine aufnahme das muss ja die anderen
europäer auch überzeugen
also man kann so den beiden sozusagen
richtungen vergleichen
die defizite vor allem und um das
wichtigste was die ukraine jetzt tun
sollte ist die bekämpfung von korruption
da wurde schon einiges gemacht ich
erinnere noch an
gesetz das sich hier präsident salewski
auch sehr an die fahnen geschrieben hat
der legalisierung gesetz
das wird manchen in der ukraine
eigentlich gar nicht genug oder gerecht
aber so wie ich höre in brüssel wurde
ist eigentlich sehr gut aufgenommen
es gibt auch bereits institutionen die
sind geschafft worden aber die
funktionieren einfach noch nicht richtig
und er ist weiter also eigentlich auch
bei
der regierung auch bei der vorherigen
regierung die haben sich etwas
vorzuwerfen und ich hoffe dass das jetzt
wirklich ein sehr wichtiger hebel sein
wert vor allem auch also ich sehe dass
die ukraine das eigentlich sehr
ambitioniert auch in dieser situation
des krieges ansieht ich habe jetzt
gelesen von also von der ukrainischen
regierung man will diese bedingungen
irgendwie bis ende des jahres
erfüllen also ich glaube das ist schon
sehr ambitioniert aber auf jeden fall
das zeigt einfach dass man wirklich also
vor hart und die erwartungen der
gesellschaft des acl sehr groß also es
könnten ja da auch viele steine in den
weg gelegt werden wir haben ja diese
woche die erstaunliche erfahrung gemacht
dass da der wolf offensichtlich einen
ganzen kreidefelsen gefressen hat
russland tut nämlich so so als hätte es
mit der ausnahme der ukraine in die
europäische union gar nichts zu tun sagt
wörtlich das sei ja eine souveräne
entscheidung der ukraine die ja
eigentlich von der landkarte tilgen will
wer hat das denn so sagt putin der
ukraine von der landkarte haben ein die
er die da sagen ich jetzt die stärke ist
die stadt nicht verstand ich dass alle
gesund der hinter ihr zu
informieren
ist einfach nicht richtig
der im moment er hat gesagt er die
ukraine hat kein recht auf staatlichkeit
ich wollte aber auch etwas anderes noch
hinaus wenn jetzt könnte man ja sagen
wenn nicht denn dass die handlung nicht
so verbrecher beschwerden der mann hat
humor aber wie ist das zu verstehen dass
putin plötzlich sagt er will die
souveräne entscheidung es ist diese war
eine entscheidung der ukraine
was steckt dahinter naja ich glaube dass
momentan der russische präsident nicht
wirklich so etwas kann ja noch machen er
hat schon irgendwie die ukraine
überfallen der verein versucht die die
das land zu vernichten und es ist ein
grausamer krieg gegen zivilisten
der russische präsident hat auch
relativ milder sozusagen jetzt auf einen
antrag von finnland und schweden in die
nato reagiert na und noch vor einiger
zeit hatte eigentlich damit dass gegen
die ukraine gerechtfertigt das jetzt
irgendwie die ukraine in die nato
aufgenommen wird und die nato die
grenzen sollte wie will denn du kriegen
wir die natur aufnehmen
im augenblick gibt es dafür aber keine
zustimmung ja aber wann der wir haben
kann
auf dem nato beitritt verzichtet habe
ich das finde er hat
angeboten hat angeboten dass es möglich
wäre bei den verhandlungen in der türkei
also man geht eigentlich ankommt
russland wirklich sehr entgegen auch in
diesen verhandlungen aber dass die
ukraine in die nato möchte steht in der
ukrainischen verfassung und daran hat
sich nichts geändert und das ist immer
noch die hoffen und gehen die pläne
eigentlich
welcher preis wäre denn möglicherweise
an putin zu entrichten das eher
akzeptiert dass die ukraine auf lange
sicht in die europäische und jung und
alt sind wenn wir von den beiden völker
rechtsprinzip hinausgehen
unverletzlichkeit der grenzen und
sanitätern des landes dann hört sie sich
nicht an des landes zu entscheiden wo es
hingeht und das blatt wollte will ja mit
seinen kriegs maßnahmen aber auch vorher
schon mit 2014 verhindern hier gibt's
das souveräne recht völkerrechtlich
april sich der ukraine diesen antrag zu
stellen wir wissen aus vielen regionen
dass es im überschaubaren zeitraum mit
der nato nichts wird
aus gutem grunde und das aus diesem
grund hat jetzt die eu
kandidaten perspektive das entsprechende
element der rest anbieten gästen die
ukraine umgestalten und auch ein stück
und politisch und in der praxis
abzusichern und ich sehe nicht alles so
negativ vielmehr so sehen dass 2014 seit
2014 andere die ukraine reformprozess
macht angesichts eines krieges im lande
und wenn ich die frau sich gesehen dass
ein krieg in dem lande ist muss ich
sehen dass trotz aller mängel in den
acht jahren viele reformfortschritte
gemacht worden sind in der justiz aber
nicht ausreichend regionalisierung und
manches andere mehr dass ein
wirtschaftlicher prozess gekommen ist
der sehr positiv ist und wir haben auch
mit der frage der wettbewerbsfähigkeit
der assoziierung der handelsvertrag
europäische union mit der ukraine hat
schon dazu geführt
dass die ukraine ein höheres maß an
wettbewerbsfähigkeit bekommen hat und
auch schon an export land gegenüber der
europäischen union geworden ist hat sich
schon positiv ausgewirkt auf die innere
stufen wirtschaftliche struktur der
ukraine und unruhig es muss man als
festhalten in der ukraine ist im
gegensatz zu manchen anderen ländern ein
friedlicher wechsel von regierung nach
waren möglich im prinzip fast nach an
waren die seit 1990 dort stattgefunden
haben das bringt nicht nur 2000
friedlich 2014 haben friedliche wahlen
stattgefunden mit einem
regierungswechsel nachdem der präsident
das land verlassen hatte und vorher
unterschrieben hatte dass er nicht mehr
kandidieren wird
bei den unruhen
herr verheugen es wird ja immer wieder
gemunkelt möglicherweise wird in länder
wie deutschland oder andere westliche
länder vielleicht die ukraine auch ein
bisschen dazu drängen zu sagen zumindest
territoriale zugeständnisse bei
möglichen waffenstillstand
friedensverhandlungen zu machen
sozusagen ich frag doch mal ist das so
eine art gegengeschäft könnte das in
diese richtung laufen
die frage ist ob die ukraine mit macht
aber ist dass ein möglicher ansatz also
dass das halte ich für fast
ausgeschlossen also den demokratischen
präsidenten möchte ich noch kennenlernen
der riss der es riskieren kann ja also
einen solchen gedanken
überhaupt nur zu bergen geschweige
geschweige denn ihn in öffentlich zu
äußern und ich glaube nicht
dass die ukraine in der lage ist
irgendeine vereinbarung was auch immer
zuzustimmen dass wir dauerhaften
verzicht auf
der italien verbunden ist auf der
anderen seite aber möchte ich darauf
hinweisen
dass die erweiterungspolitik der
europäischen union auch nicht zu lasten
dritter gehen darf sein grundsatz
bedienen überhaupt nicht mehr über mehr
gesprochen wird darauf hinweisen dass
seinerzeit
als ja eine ganze reihe von
nachbarstaaten russlands aufgenommen
wurden die russland betreffenden fragen
intensiv mit den russen besprochen
worden sind und das auch in allen fällen
übereinstimmung erzielt wurde und
teilweise auch abkommen abgeschlossen
worden zb einst die europäische union im
augenblick gerade bricht und mit den
großen wert darauf dass ihr festzuhalten
was im augenblick passiert im hinblick
auf den
transitverkehr von russland in die
exklave kaliningrad durch litauen ist
ein eindeutiger bruch
bilateraler abkommen und internationale
abkommen und ich sage ihnen hier wird
wohl das
überhaupt nichts zu tun der ungehinderte
transit von gütern von russland in das
in oblast kaliningrad ist garantiert in
partnerschaften kooperationen zu
bekommen wir haben den russen 2002
versprochen und es ist auch durch die
wto regeln so festgelegt hier wird
bewusst
und willentlich die lunte an ein
pulverfass gelegt und ich frage mich
wird nicht er hat wer hat ein interesse
daran nachdem wir den jetzt bereits
einen schrecklichen konflikt haben auch
noch einen zweiten territorialen
konflikt in dieser region vorzubereiten
wie sehen sie diese entwicklung
es geht ja ums unschuldig daran ist
dass die situation noch weiter
geht darum dass es gibt einen einen
eisenbahn korridor zwischen weißrussland
und
60 ist kein korridor das ist hier genau
das was damals verhindert haben die
kröte und dekor der lösung haben die
russen haben was daran exterritorial ja
das wäre also kein korridor ist eine
ganz normale ganz normale
eisenbahnverbindung auf litauisch und
der eto o das ist ein nato land holen
auch dass er so genannte dazu wald gibt
der ist etwas solider ist breit da
fahren also diese güter von russland
weißrussland nach litauen
verschärft dass die situation lenkt das
von der ukraine ab wie sehen sie das
jetzt auch im vergleich mit den konflikt
in der ukraine also im vergleich zum
krieg in so kleinen also dass das land
nicht ab und in die ukraine wie täglich
gekämpft
soweit ich verstehe dass in sanktions
utah die jetzt
also nicht gebracht werden dürfen
geht von russland nach russland ja es
ist keine export und ich sehe nicht dass
für eine unnötige geschichte was da
gegenwärtig mit dem transit gemacht
werden
richtig ist sondern ist es einfach es
gibt bestimmte punkt in solchen krisen
wo man dann nicht hingucken wenn ich es
mal so sagen darf und das fass
aufzumachen dieser frage halte ich
einfach unklug aber halten sie das für
eine provokation gegeben und bei
russland also dass russland
bewusst es ist eine bewusste provokation
wird hier bewusst eskaliert würde gerne
wissen wer
dahinter steckt wir haben doch kein
interesse an einer eskalation der
konflikte mit russland wir können doch
nur ein interesse haben hier war wieder
mal wieder runterzukommen und irgendwann
noch mal wieder zusammenzuarbeiten und
da habe ich die gelegenheit benutzen
einem einer idee zu widersprechen die
sie am anfang geäußert haben als sie
gesagt haben die naivste aller
vorstellungen sei es gewesen man könne
einen wirtschaftsraum von wladiwostok
bis lissabon oder umgekehrt schafft ich
widerspreche dem ganz entschieden das
war beete eine naive noch naivste idee
es war die einzig richtige und es ist
auch jetzt noch stehen einige gerichte
und das hat übrigens auch eine ganze
reihe von jahren hervorragend
funktioniert lieber selber
verantwortlich für für einen vierten
teil der der sektoren in dieser
strategischen partnerschaft mit russland
das einfach nicht wahr zu sagen dass das
nicht funktionieren kann und dazu hätte
ich eine gegenfrage also ich habe ja
bereits aber etwas dabei gedacht hat
sich das formuliert habe wenn man an
mario pohl und putzer deckt glauben sie
dass wir beide noch erleben dass man mit
russland in einer guten nachbarschaft
für den frieden leben das weiß dass das
weiß ich nicht aber wenn wir über mario
pohl und bus starten und müssen uns die
frage stellen was ist geschehen
zwischen den jahren in denen diese
partnerschaft mit russland funktioniert
hat und an der situation in dem das
möglich war was ist was ist in diesem
jahr passiert was hat das glücklich
gemacht das ist dass das ist doch sie
hat eine diktatur geworden ist das ist
denn auch
das wäre rechtlich kriegsverbrechen in
der ukraine wird rechtfertigt dass die
gleichen der ungerechtfertigt nicht
rechtfertigt diesen diesen angriff aber
es ist auch einfach nicht richtig zu
sagen dass die gesamte politik die die
europäische union deutschland und viele
andere
nach 19
1999 betrieben am fall sparen ich
beziehe dieses wir haben uns geirrt des
bundespräsidenten ausdrücklich nicht ob
mich also für mich hat der
bundespräsident nicht gesprochen als er
gesagt hat wir haben uns geirrt ich
würde alles was ein mensch der fehler
bestand darin das richtige nämlich die
europäische sicherheitsarchitektur die
wir haben wollen nicht erschlossen genug
verteidigt zu haben gegen diejenigen die
kein interesse daran hat dass der
vorwurf den sich anschließen würde
lassen sie uns auf die etwas
naheliegendere zukunft zurückkommen wir
haben darüber gesprochen was sich die
ukraine von der europäischen union
erhofft aber was kann sich die
europäische union eigentlich von der
ukraine erhoffen profitieren denn wir
auch von der ukraine könnte man ja an
deutschland denken ein land das
wettbewerbsfähig ist das exportstärke
hat in der europäischen union die
führenden wirtschaftsnationen ist haben
denn zb wir aus wirtschaftlichen gründen
auch ein großes interesse eines tages
die ukraine als
eu mitglied zu haben also wir haben
natürlich generell ein interesse in
einem möglichst großen binnenraum
wirtschaften zu können
das berührt übrigens wenn immer
zwangsläufig auch negative die
interessen von russland denn wenn sie
jetzt die ukraine in die europäische
union integrieren dann kommt es zur
sogenannten handels um lenkungseffekte
das heißt der handel innerhalb der
europäischen union auch mit der ukraine
intensiviert sich sie haben aber einen
gemeinsamen außen- zoll und sonstige im
außen verkehr wirksame barrieren die
dann natürlich tendenziell die
wirtschaftlichen beziehungen zwischen
russland und der ukraine
schwächen der momentan ist das schwer
vorstellbar weil die kriegs effekte
einfach vieles gar nicht möglich machen
manches vielleicht auch gar nicht
denkbar machen im moment aber wenn wir
mal die längere perspektive nehmen
sollte man sich natürlich schon
überlegen ob man nicht auch für die
wirtschaftliche kooperation in richtung
russland
erweitert dann aber natürlich unter der
klaren voraussetzung dass man wieder
friedlich miteinander umgeht das ist
ganz klar das würde ja auch daneben für
diejenigen kräfte in russland die es
hoffentlich noch gibt die diesen krieg
auch nicht wollen eben auch noch mal
einen positiven anreiz bieten sich von
diesem putin system abzulösen und auch
in russland zu einer veränderung zu
kommen ansonsten ist es vielleicht die
europäische union selber die mal drüber
nachdenken soll ob sie noch auf einem
ganz
guten weg ist so wie sich entwickelt hat
nämlich immer mehr auch in richtung
einer umverteilung
institution und das kann durchaus dazu
führen dass es große widerstände geben
wird wenn wir beispielsweise auf die
gemeinsame agrarpolitik schauen ob wir
nun einen der wichtigsten weltweit
wichtigsten agrar produzenten wie die
ukraine in diesen binnenmarkt mit
einbeziehen wollen das ist aber nichts
wo ich sagen würde da müssen wir
irgendwie federn lassen oder uns ist
etwas kosten lassen sondern das wäre
vielleicht sogar ein ganz guter anlass
dass die union die europäische union
selber wieder etwas abnimmt diese ganzen
umverteilungs menschen darauf zu
bekommen häufig kann es sein dass wir
möglicherweise das umgekehrt gedacht wir
die dass uns der beitritt der ukraine
moment zu teuer kommt und dass deswegen
schwierigkeiten gibt in europa in der
europäischen union die
beitrittsverhandlungen zu beschleunigen
und so weit ich verstehe jetzt also zum
weit weg bekommt das jetzt nicht also
dass das ein weiteres könnte und das ist
ein noch ein weg die ukraine hat noch
vieles zu tun
und die ukraine hat sehr wohl etwas
anzubieten also sie haben da die
wirtschaft jetzt erwähnt ich denke vor
allem gerade weil ich in deutschland
auch lebern digitalisierung also da sind
die unterschiede
gravierend und die ukrainische
flüchtling geht jetzt nach deutschland
kommen die reiben sich die augen wie es
möglich ist so schlank wie die
spezialisten bei
der deutschen wirtschaft und jetzt
weniger der ukrainischen
das ist ja sozial ein israeli trainer
nicht so schlecht sind ja wäre an sich
also was ich auch wenn ich darf noch
ganz kurz erwischt ich hinter also
gerade in dieser zeit so wie sie sagen
dann nach büchern nach europa liefern
wir hier darüber reden wir weiter wissen
dass mit diesem los man's machen und
wieder so naiv und wir sind wir
deutschland in den letzten jahren was
der präsident gesagt hat sich geirrt hat
ich weiß nicht ob geehrt oder einfach zu
ignorant gewesen war und dachte
irgendwie ach es kommt nicht und das
wird nicht passieren aber wir haben wir
sehen doch dass es doch eine lange zeit
wir sehen können und zum schluss kommen
können dass diese politik gegenüber
russland immer gescheitert ist diese
angst politik nicht funktioniert sind in
der abteilung reform in der eu als
voraussetzung für erweiterung herr brok
da muss man jetzt eigentlich erstmal
hier die hausaufgaben machen das ist ja
heute schon mal gefallen das
einstimmigkeitsprinzip in
aussenpolitischen sprachen auflösen den
haushalt reformieren die
aufnahmefähigkeit
zu definieren das sind ja die
sogenannten erweiterungs voraussetzungen
ist das ein aspekt der diese die
aufnahmen nicht mehr der ukraine sondern
auch der westbalkan staaten erheblich
verzögern wird ganz entscheidend man hat
den richtigen schritt mit dem
kandidatenstatus für die beiden länder
getroffen aber man hat nicht die eigenen
bedingungen für kopenhagen live
ansprachen gehört auch die
aufnahmefähigkeit europäische union wir
haben bei der erweiterung 2004 2007 mit
den verträgen amsterdam nutzer und
lissabon das vertiefung und erweiterung
zusammen gesehen und die
entscheidungsfähigkeit dann erweitern
europäischen union zu sehen wir haben
nicht alles erreicht aber vieles
erreicht in der frage und das muss man
jetzt auch wieder machen wir sind mit
der westbalkan dazu kommt und die drei
staaten dort sind wir 36 staaten das
erhöht die wahrscheinlichkeit dass immer
ein bekloppter dabei ist ein veto
einlegt ist eine rechnerische prahl und
deswegen ist die erde ist der
verbesserung der
entscheidungsmechanismen osteuropäischen
eine bedingung eine bedingung für die
erweiterung der europäischen union und
die länder die besonders intensiv jetzt
für die erweiterung werben sie zum teil
diejenigen die am wenigsten reform der
oberen wollen die nordischen staaten
einigen mittel- und osteuropa und das
muss in aller härte gesagt werden unter
scheitern dieses gipfel steht jetzt
schon fest weil der reform agenda der
europäischen zukunftsplans die das
europäische parlament beantragt jetzt
hat in diesem gibt wird nichts zustande
kommt die französische präsidentschaft
ihre zusagen diese frage nicht
eingehalten hat und deswegen ist eine
weitere
klausel wie sie jetzt die ukraine
bekommen hat ohne diese frage der selbst
ertüchtigung der europäischen union in
der tat ein danaergeschenk darf ich da
habe ich darf etwas über wir sind ganz
einig in dieser frage nur die
erfahrungen der letzten
15 jahre lehrt uns eines
ein neuer eu vertrag der die
erkennbaren schweren defizite die wir ja
haben in der in der in der
entscheidungsfindung mit susan aufbau in
dem politik bereit ein neuer vertrag der
das der diese probleme lösen würde ist
nach meiner festen überzeugung in
absehbarer zeit nicht erreicht man kann
endgültig prozent der dinge ohne
vergangene vertrags in rovinj will heute
sagen immer auch dazu auf dazu braucht
man erst einmal einstimmigkeit nein doch
worauf einmal noch die einstimmigkeit
abzuschalten
der welt einzuberufen reicht die
einfache mehrheit im rat wir haben sich
darauf war anständig dennoch im konsens
entscheiden der seite schleudern selbst
ihre märz umstellen
wir haben leider nur noch zwei minuten
ein aspekt noch der den wir noch nicht
angesprochen haben wenn ich jetzt
albaner kosovo serben und mazedonier
oder multi kriener wäre auch was müsste
ich mich einstellen in sachen
europäische union
sagt nimmerleinstag oder
erst mal müssen die nut zum teil ihren
laden in ordnung in bosnien herzegowina
ist nicht aufgegangen es ist nicht
einfach
und solange kosovo und serbien ihre
probleme nicht gelöst dann geht es auch
nicht nord mazedonien wird unfair
behandelt das steht fest und das ist
aber jetzt bewegung in bulgarien drin
als zu kurz vor dem gipfel gekommen das
wird man in kürze lösen aber die länder
müssen ihren laden in ordnung bringen
aber wir müssen wirklich diese
zwischenschritte anboten die anbieten
die für ihn im zusammenhang mit der
ukraine irland habe nicht dieses alles
oder nichts das wird nichts und deswegen
muss man dort wo man fortschritte macht
das muss man ansammeln das ist mein
großer teil des rki hat die länder wie
österreich und so weiter die über den
europäischen wirtschaftsunion
reingekommen sind die hatten damit schon
60 70 polizei an bord und ob man die
mittels verhandlung relativ einfach und
leicht weil vieles war und deswegen muss
man an diese tradition wieder
anschließen und nicht dieses alles oder
nichts machen damit werden die
verhältnisse innerhalb der europäischen
union also dieses europa der
unterschiedlichen geschwindigkeiten das
eigentlich ganz mart dass ich erst mal
diejenigen zusammenfinden die normal
weiter vorangehen sollte
gesagt werden wir auch anschließend und
zwar in der nächsten runde zu diesem
thema ich bedanke mich bei natalia
fiebrig bei elmar brok günther verfolgen
und bei stefan kooths user ich hatte
noch für sie einen reisetipp für die
nächsten tage gehen sie mit uns mit
phoenix auf gipfel wanderung bis freitag
ist noch eu-gipfel von sonntag bis
dienstag treffen sich die g7 staaten zu
ihrem gipfel auf schloss elmau bei
garmisch und dann wird sich fast der
gesamte tross wieder auf reisen begeben
nachdem attraktion nato-gipfel spannende
zeiten und all das bei phoenix
jetzt folgt phoenix der tag mit mayer
weber darin all das andere große thema
von heute robert habeck hat die
alarmstufe des notfallplans gas
ausgerufen alles weitere auch jetzt zu
brüssel eben in der in der sendung
phoenix der tag bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]